good morning everyone we'll call the
meeting to order
foreign
and everybody's
seated
any additions deletions or corrections
to the minutes
seeing none all those in favor
and emotion on a consent agenda does
any discussion all those in favor
Mr chairman yes
who is representative Gruen sitting for
today
whoever
[Music]
I believe it's uh Department of Revenue
2022-132 is the first on the regular
agenda
this particular proposal there was a
conditional approval filed however
there were five substantive comments and
one comment to jail car still remaining
on that conditional approval
the first was on page four it's an
unclear comment about all amounts
charged must be included in the amount
of the gross charge
which conflicts with later Provisions in
the rule as those later Provisions
layout exceptions so therefore it's not
all charges must be gross charges there
are actually exceptions so there are
some
issues with that particular rule
I don't know if the department wants to
respond to that before I move on to the
good morning uh Keen Ming Wong
Department of Revenue
the um
these so just want to start off with
saying that these uh these rules were as
um
attorney uh
your card has pointed out in her
comments that uh these were already
addressed in the 2012 um Joker meeting
and it was passed back back then
um and look through the uh the files
the historical files and um couldn't
really see any
um notes that was written down as to
what was discussed back in 2012 in the
jail club meeting I couldn't bring any
more additional information uh to sort
of
discuss
the uh the outcome of that but
ultimately uh
it was approved and then I
and I was went back to the um the RSA in
terms of these uh the 1602.01 A and it
is
addressing RSA
82-a colon 2 Roman 5 all the uh the
growth the the charges that's considered
as um as gross charge and then
specifically I think it is also
addressing subpart e where it says
charges for services so which is um so
that that list of charges there is the
exception of what should not be in Gross
charge and it's a party he says that you
know charges for services which are not
provided in connection with the
origination or receiving communication
Services
um and so this part here it looks like
to me when I was reading through this
1602.01 a addresses more on this support
e where it says okay what's not here
would be here as accepted as should be
considered as taxable items in the gross
charge
yes
so this is not resolved no not at this
time
yes
thank you
could it be
reasonable to say that all amounts
except those specifically Exempted
I mean really you've got the exemptions
are very specific and narrow yeah you
just need to include make sure that
yes it looks like it's it's like a like
a um
sort of a uh an opening statement say
okay all charges share our gross charges
and then there's this
thing here as uh the attorney uh the
staff attorney had mentioned making
reference to the later rev rules of
1602.02 160 2.03 B and those
well those are what services by the
retailer that shall not be included in
the growth charge
and in 16 so just for an example 1602.02
it says uh support a say Services
provided by a retailer that shall not be
included in close charge but then when
you look back to 1602.01
um it does say all charges
but used in by customers in connection
with origination or reception of
communication services
shall be included in amount of those
charge whereas
in 1602.02
um
so what are the services that is not in
there so in A1 it says those which are
not directly overlayed so there's no
there's no conflict I don't see the
conflict between a 160201a
and O2 A1 because it sort of coughs it
out
um but
so just make sure I'm clear you're
saying that the later sections are
different than the origination or
reception of communicating services and
that's why they're not considered
exceptions to all gross charges it's
it's not
I will say there might be some overlap
in terms of trying to carve out what's
not a growth charge
um and I think the 160201 is is this
blanket statement trying to capture all
I would say that language is
therefore unclear because you're saying
that there's some overlay but those are
exceptions when you're saying all
um
I guess my other point may not be a
strong point to say that but um since
these rules have been in place since
2012 oh we have not had any issues from
yeah we're not bound by the errors of
the past yeah
about so I'm just trying to point out
that um we haven't received any kind of
uh confusion comments from from um
taxpayers or retailers who are filing
these returns
um saying that okay yeah we're not
there's no certainty or there's
if there are no more
questions regarding that particular
comment uh the next comment which first
appears on page 14 but then is
reiterated on pages 16 22 and 23
is an authority legislative intent no to
jail car comment this has to do with
that Pains of penalty language we
discussed at the last meeting appearing
on forms when there's no statutory
Authority for that however because we
discussed at the last meeting and it
seems the department is moving forward
with legislation to fix that if that
legislation goes through that would fix
the comments on this particular rule as
well so the next uh substantive comment
is on the bottom of page 14 it's an
unclear comment that says that the
statute shall apply but it does not say
what the statute shall apply to in the
original
proposal they had originally cited
another statute but in the conditional
approval have struck that statute due to
so the um the original language is that
saying that the uh the underpayment
panel the underpayment penalties shall
apply to the communication Services tax
RSA 82-a
um and so receiving the comment from
staff attorney saying that okay shall
not
make reference to a2-a that's the reason
why I took it out
well the problem was the way the rule
was written in the proposal was saying
that this statute shall apply to this
other statute but the statutory language
did not reference
that at all so you were essentially
using a rule to say that a statute shall
apply to another statute which is not
within the authority of the department
um
I guess so then we are okay to strike
out that entire um support B because it
does say well I guess within the 21j32
it does say that um
that underpayment penalty does apply to
um rs-82 a within that particular
statute itself so I probably we don't
need that in in in the rule here that's
if that's all right with the committee
to just write that language yeah go
ahead the next comment's an unclear
comment on page 19 the department uses
the term substantial to measure
the penalty attributable to or a measure
to of whether or not a penalty will be
invoked
to an understatement of tax liability
it's also used to measure the legal
Authority required to avoid liability
for an understatement which might
otherwise impose that legal liability so
using the term substantial as a means of
measurement to invoke a penalty and to
say that whether or not someone has
enough legal Authority is not clear and
is in violation of RSA 541 A1 because
there's no criteria on how the
department is actually going to
determine that on a case-by-case basis
so for the first substantial Authority
comment which is on
1611.01 A2
um and then it goes on to if we look at
1611.01 C
it says in determining whether whether a
retailer or customer has substantial
Authority so detection consider the
following
um and those are the things that that
the uh department will be looking into
this to determine whether there is that
substantial Authority by the retailer
customer
and one with that motion
Senator Gray
I think that what we've heard here is
that there's still a lot of Staff work
to be done on this one and that the
comments from
The Joker staff really haven't been
addressed by the department and so I
we have a motion on a second any further
discussion
huh
all those in favor
aye
do you know where the office is you
should go visit them
and the next item on the regular agenda
is item 202262 from the Department of
Safety
uh this particular rule um the
department also filed a conditional
approval which addressed a majority of
Staff comments however there is still
one substantive comment remaining
on page two there's an unclear comment
as the rule
states that every sexual offender or
offender against children shall register
and references the statutes but the
statutes are circular in that the
definition of a
sexual offender
or offender against children say anyone
who needs to be registered and then when
you look at the other statute the
statute says that every sexual offender
or Fender against children shall
register so there's no real clear
definition of of what that is this
comment was made on the conditional
approval text from 2012 and the
committee did approve the language at
that time but it seems that there was no
I was told that a representative from
safety would be here it's not the normal
attorney
she said that she was going to be out
but that someone else would be here but
it appears as though
do you have a recommendation on this
I I don't have a specific recommendation
as I said this language was approved
before but
um once as you said chairman that we're
not bound by the past so if the
committee feels as though this is enough
to be a preliminary objection it would
allow the department of me more time to
talk and then see if we can come to a
resolution about that or we can accept
the conditional approval as is and leave
that language there for now
um
representative McGuire yes thank you Mr
chair I move we approve the rule with
the recommendation that the department
Motion in a second any discussion all
those in favor
next
electrologists okay so um this proposal
makes changes to the licensing rules for
Alcohol and Other Drug use professionals
laid acts and laid acts Etc
the agency has filed a conditional
approval request but there are still a
few comments that remain the first issue
is on page 17 of the conditional
approval request page 18 of the PDF
there's been some testimonies submitted
stating that the rule violates the
statute because it does not allow for
remote supervision on a platform like
Zoom the rule does allow for indirect
supervision and it defines that as being
telephonic the statute doesn't
explicitly state that either clinical
supervision or supervised practical
training can be done remotely and it
doesn't Define what indirect supervision
means it also doesn't Define what a
location is whether a location can be a
remote location
um we know that technology like Zoom
would allow for video and not just audio
like the the telephonic what what's
currently in the role but this may be a
policy decision for the board
um so that's what that first note is
about if you want um Tina could respond
to that before we move on to the next
item
good morning I'm Tina Kelly I'm the
program specialist with the office of
professional licensure and certification
and if you look under C of that section
it says supervised practical training
that includes direct and indirect
supervision both direct and indirect
supervision are defined in
ALC 301.01 ink
and one of those it just has to be a
combination of both one of those allows
for uh telephonic and those types of um
they and we don't put specifically Zoom
we just telephonic or remote
and I can read the definition if you
um I don't know about you the others but
I don't actually need you to read that
okay what I would like to see is that if
there's a reference to those things that
it be put into this paragraph
um as a part of the conditional approval
for this and therefore I think that
it's defined there
um so do you want me to put in a direct
includes direct supervision as defined
in 301
I'm happy to have you work that out with
staff or indirect supervision and as
defined yeah I can yeah that's easy
enough to add that's okay pretty much
editorial you'd say
um or is that substantive it's a little
something we can make it as part of the
conditional approval request okay
so I'll move on to the next item and
that's on pages 26 and 27 it also
involves a comment on page
33. let me just scroll down there
um
uh here the rule is talking about the
application or licensing requirements
for those holding an out of state
license a testimony has been submitted
stating that the statute allows for
automatic licensing but it doesn't the
board has to waive the supervised work
and practical training experience to
anyone submitting proof of active
practice for a period of five years
initially we were thinking that the
requirement
of submission of an official transcript
as you see there highlighted that's the
sub paragraph four that that may be
beyond what is necessary given that the
board has to waive those requirements
the supervised in Practical training
requirements but the statute does allow
the board to license folks whose
academic study has been less than what's
required in New Hampshire is certain
other requirements are met so we think
that's probably the reason why this
requirement is here was without that
they wouldn't know what coursework the
person actually has but there is an
issue around the the rural language and
that's on page 27 and also on page 23
where it's talking about that the person
has to have an active proof of active
practice for 10 years
the statute talks about five years
so we've placed like I said that comment
occurs also on page 33 and with that I
can let Tina address that
yep the um the clarification of why the
board's asking for the transcripts is
exactly correct it's because it's so
different but we can change the 10 years
to five years I did look at the statute
and the statute it's very clear it's
um and then the last comment is on page
58 of The Proposal but 59 of the PDF and
that's really a comment letting the
committee know that the board still does
retain some fee Authority in the
statutes and that's the only comments I
have and this is a conditional approval
request
Carol yes thank you I move we approve
the conditional
approval request with the addition of
the correction of 10 years to five years
in at least two places and the other
editorial comments recommended by staff
and I believe that the fee Authority
question is being addressed in
legislation
Motion in a second any discussion
all those in favor
aye any objections
yes so the board did submit a draft
conditional approval however it sounds
as though there was some technical
difficulties over at the oplc which
prevented them from officially
submitting that conditional approval but
I was able to talk to uh Miss Kelly
prior to this meeting to discuss the
remaining comments after reviewing that
draft conditional approval and came up
with solutions to address those specific
concerns so at this time the conditional
approval
would be what was submitted as a draft
in addition to changing the form that
says pharmacist and advanced pharmacy
technicians application that was
submitted with the final proposal to
pharmacists certified pharmacy
technicians and Pharmacy interns
application to administer vaccines to
change the section where it says
pharmacy license to just say license or
certification so that the certified
pharmacy techs and interns could also
use that application and then to change
the rule itself to say instead of just
pharmacists shall apply pharmacists
certified pharmacy techs and Pharmacy
interns as the new statute does allow
all three of these
Pharmacy Personnel to administer
questions
motion
so I think for this um you have she
sorry the department has to request
um the conditional approval based on
um the draft submitted and the other
comments of attorney Ricard and then
um
jailcar has to waive the deadline
because they they're filing it here at
any discussion all those in favor
and
um and then you would accept the our
move to accept the draft conditional
approval with the extra comments okay
any discussion
I'll lose some favor
okay um this proposal
um
see is on the requirements for Renewal
reinstatement and continuing education
requirements for licensees for
veterinarians there are two comments and
on the amended conditional approval that
you have before you and I'll just
mention the easiest one first and that's
on page 10 of the proposal and the PDF
they're the rule cites to the vet 800s
which doesn't currently exist but the
agency is currently enroll regular rule
making for that rule set the second
comment is right there on page one the
rules have been expired since January 28
of 2020 the statute does establish a
health program fee and that became
effective in this year and then the PLC
has established some rules also in some
other
um in some other has established some
fees and some other rules and those also
have have effective dates in this year
so the committee may have some questions
about the collection of fees and any
refunds that have been done during that
time period in which the rule was
expired and the statutes weren't
effective
good morning for the record Lindsey
Courtney executive director office of
professional Ace insurance certification
with respect to the first comment
regarding the vet 800s what we would
propose is to have the board adopt each
set of rules concurrently at the same
time so as to avoid reference to a rule
that's not in effect with respect to the
fee issue as the committee is aware the
board of veterinary medicine was
previously attached to the Department of
Agriculture they were in the process of
rulemaking at the time that they were
transferred over to the office
think it was two budget Cycles ago
um the rules expired in January 2020
um and but obviously that was an
oversight on our part in terms of not
understanding that uh the fees were
captured in our mlo database that has
since been corrected and about
240 individuals have been issued refunds
to date it is a manual process so it is
taking some time there are currently a
thousand licensed veterinarians so it
requires us to review each licensee
record to assess whether or not a fee
was improperly charged and to issue the
appropriate refund I did attempt to uh
to obtain some documentation to support
that our reporting was a little bit
difficult in that it's a manual process
and includes
protected financial information
but if the committee would like for
their documentation we can continue to
okay
okay I had no further comment and um
this is a conditional approval actually
Carol
I move we accept the conditional amended
conditional approval request and uh
thank the oplc for issuing the refunds
thank you
second
we have this Motion in a second only
question that I have was about uh 800
um the
director had said adopting him
concurrently
yeah um I don't see it as necessarily as
our problem that these that the rule set
you know that this rule refers to
non-existing rules they are in the
process of doing regular rule making I
have reviewed the 800s so I think that
they're going to be moving forward soon
with that rule set I believe in the next
month right
so we would be looking at a January gel
card date possibly a December I think
it depends but yeah the latest would be
January are you going to have a gel car
by December
turn off my mic yeah
okay
there has only been one instance in the
history of gel car where they were not
able to meet in December after uh
organization yes
okay did you vote
I think he moved but didn't vote right
okay okay thank you so we have a motion
in a second
any other discussion
seeing none all those in favor
aye
and next
hey um next we have an amended
conditional approval
um on the prescription drug
affordability rules this proposal would
establish organizational rules for the
board and rules outlining the board's
operations there are three comments to
bring to your attention we have received
this morning from representative Lang a
document about 15 minutes before the
committee began that have not had a
chance to review
and I have just forwarded we've just
forwarded that over to the agency as
well I can go ahead and get into the the
comments that I have in the rule
um the first one
is on page 18 of the PDF
and um
here
okay oh yes so actually it's on page one
and that's just an informational note
there kind of giving you the background
uh for the for the rule itself and the
fact that um
hb1208 had an effective date of 2020 so
you may have some questions about
whether or not the board has been
meeting and issuing reports as required
by the um by the underlying statute
don't know if you want me to go ahead
and turn it over to Allison or continue
on to the next comment is your
evaluation complete or are you waiting
for
do you still have other things to review
now there are a few other things on here
to go over
um let's see the like I said this on the
next comment is on page 18 and
um here also that that page is going to
say page one because this Begins the the
second set of rules the 300s
um so here we we've received a comment
because the rule basically restates
what's in the statute and
um and it does mostly do that but the
board has added some additional
information around data sets that
they're going to be considering it
determining the annual spending targets
the board may need to do some additional
rulemaking in the future as they kind of
Flesh that out in order to figure out
what the spending targets should be
the next comment is on page 20 of the
PDF and that's going to say page three
at the top here the statute says that
the board may may look into you know
getting funds and grants and contracts
to augment their assessment fees and
that is what the statute says and in
response to my comment the board has
struck that out but I we do know that
often
agencies do not have to commit their
process for accepting grants funds or
contracts within the rules so um with
that I had no other comments
Mr chair
I I don't know if you in your question
uh you were referring to the email that
representative Lang had received we have
not reviewed that comment yet apparently
the and representative Lang certainly
can talk more about it but apparently
someone questioned the constitutionality
of the fees uh in the rules
yeah
um sorry about that if that's what you
meant no I have not reviewed it yet
um it appears to be a 14-page document
um
and um like I said neither me nor the
agency has reviewed it yet
um as far as I know the sport is not
assessing fines or fees per se they do
have some assessment fees so I'm not
really sure what exactly the issue is
and in the document until until I've had
a chance to look at it so and this is
outside of the public hearing process
yes sir
hard to consider
when there was an opportunity to comment
so there are um
this is a 14-page document written in
2013 so there's a large time Gap but it
was written by Marcus Hearn who's very
um
well respected
um scholar in the area so it would
definitely be something that we would
like to review and consider however you
have a few options you can either
approve today
um do a preliminary objection based on
staff comments which would give us more
time to review this and then we would
have to ask the potentially ask the the
board for a revised objection response
um but if you you approve it you can we
can also then still go back take the
time review everything and you can come
back with a petition if something needs
to be changed
and and I could report out to the
committee next time you know my review
and and um Christine is correct I I was
a student of Marcus Hearn and have a
great deal of respect for him so I think
receiving it at this late date doesn't
give me an adequate time to really
review
um his analysis Carol
thank you Mr chair I'm concerned that
somebody brings forth an eight-year-old
objection to fees and fines which we
have been imposing for
however many years which in this memo
was written before this board was
created
so I'm not sure how it can apply
it should be either applying to all
entities in the state or it's
it's obsolete and I'm not sure we should
take it more seriously than to actually
than
um so seriously enough just based on my
very preliminary review of skimming this
14-page document
um I do think that he may have a point
he's
he's connecting
fees or fines or whatever you call them
to the the benefit or the thing that the
the person gets back
um so you pay a fee you get your license
um and so I think in this situation
there may be a point but like I said we
can if you do approve we can go back and
we'll do the analysis still and then
recommend if the petition is needed that
way they can move forward and we will
still go ahead and take the time to
review fine in that case what I would
Rec I would move that we approve the
rule and request the agency to report on
the cost benefit of their fees
because
they should know what it is second
and that would be for an amended
conditional approval
yes
any discussion
you're okay with that Gary
so I guess my only question is there a
timeliness issue with this that forces
us to move forward today given the fact
that we may have a constitutional issue
so we've just asked for them to go ahead
and review
field but we've been proven the rule as
it's written and then they'd have to
come back with another amendment and go
through rule number again no to come
back with an analysis that justifies
that the fees only
the fees align with the benefits that
they're provided to the people who are
paying the fee
and if the benefit if the analysis does
not show that then we can object and
require them to return the fees or
whatever
yeah sure
um representative Gary Merchant
um to your question Senator Reagan I
any other discussion
seeing none all those in favor
aye any objections
Mr chair yes I think that that in light
of this reminder that we
that we keep an eye out for fees and
expect
future fee setting authority to have a
an analysis of the benefits because
we need that to decide if it's
and Department of Health and Human
Services
hey yes sir um these two proposals I'm
going to lump them together because they
deal with the same sort of issue or they
have the same issue they both of these
proposals make amendments to the rules
on licensing and the radiation safety
requirements for radiators and for wire
line service operators
there is a one comment that's applicable
to both proposals both at a citation to
hep4
1038 which is the rule on physical
protection of category one and Category
2 materials the fiscal impact statement
didn't address whether or not there
would be an increase in cost for the
entities to comply with ATP
4038 the agency didn't talk about it in
its request for fiscal impact that it's
submitted to the LBA and I reached out
to the agency and it's subject matter
experts said that and I'm summarizing
here
and the agency is here and probably can
correct me that after 9 11 it was
required to administratively add all the
federal requirements to the licensing
requirements and I think those Federal
requirements were in 10 CFR 37 so it was
added as an additional licensing a
separate additional licensing
requirement it sounded like adding now
adding in this citation and requirements
to the to the Hep 4038 will basically
have no impact but again the agency is
here and can answer any questions about
that
good morning Nicole valenzola Department
of Health and Human Services
administrative rules coordinator uh yes
thank you oh sorry
good morning senators and
representatives my name is Augustine is
all last names OMG I'm the administrator
for the radiological health section
uh so yes as attorney Reeves said um
there are no new requirements being put
forth on licensees they've already been
established in CFR and through the
nuclear Regulatory Commission uh
therefore this was an update to site to
include the rule
yes
thank you for that information However
the fact that it's new to the rule
is I can't believe that a new section of
of federal rules has no cost impact
whatsoever and I think that this change
to the rule
should have been addressed
and I'm very concerned that you think
there's no cost impact and nobody needs
to worry about
a new Federal Regulation so it's not a
new federal record it's new to the rule
it wasn't in the previous version
the fact that it was applied by the
federal government is one thing
but
if you waited 11 years to impose it it's
a new rule for people that that are just
looking at your rules
membership
yes I think I could address that so
since uh 911 the nuclear Regulatory
Commission uh issue emergency order to
secure uh the use of certain types of
materials that are classified as
category one and category two those
reactive materials are of such a high
activity that could impact the health
and safety of those using the material
or for the security of this country so
that being said then the emergency order
that was issued by NRC shortly after 9
11 were to have
the agreement states of which New
Hampshire is one whereby we could
through that emergency order to
administratively add those security
conditions onto the then current
licenses so that being said that had
exists have exists since 9 11. so
finally in our c
um I would say less than 10 years ago
finally issue the formal part 38 I'm
sorry part 37 which is the security of
the category one and two so that being
that so since the uh those rules became
or regulations became fully uh adopted
at the national level that would enable
the agreement states to then issue those
rules
all right under our own 4038 which is
the equivalent part so by having the 40
38 now becoming fully adopted and
effective we remove the administrative
conditions from those previous licenses
thereby uh creating uh uh more why would
I say correct version of the license
whereby it's the citation of 40 38
instead of relying on non-existing 4038
and simply those conditions that were
administratively added sir I agree that
the the federal agency issued this
emergency rule however are you aware
that our state constitution not the
Federal Constitution for business from
adopting any federal rule without
legislative approval yes I understand
that well it sounds like you're
in 2011 you adopted the federal rule
without legislative approval and now
you're trying to bring It Forward saying
well we did it 11 years ago it's no big
deal okay and I'm very concerned that
that is the case
understood
so I I mean I could be misunderstanding
the rule 40 38 has already been in place
so if 4038 isn't a new rule it's just
citing to it
it's just this rule is are there
requirements on the licensees in section
I mean I'm assuming I'm sure he can
Augie can speak to specific
requirements yes well regarding
categories are new requirements for the
licensees when they when they uh when
they apply for it it's a new new section
they have to comply with
they're all so it's not a new section
they're complying with because they're
already part of they're already doing it
they're already complying with it
through
being this rule is just encompassing
that citation but that rule is already
on those folks they're already complying
yes
the 4038 which is the physical
protection of the category one and two
that was adopted effectively uh in May
on whose authority
here
um just a clarification is that the
document that you're reading from is
that the rule is that the statute is it
and to comment on staff on after you get
done entering the first question
okay so um Hep
um 4038 is on uh the it's on the
physical protection of category and
category one and Category 2 quantities
of radioactive material and it looks
like it was adopted as they said in May
of 2016.
whether or not
um
you know whether or not the current
entities are the exact same entities
um
I that I don't know I'd have to dig into
this a little bit but
um to find out whether or not
um it sounded as if from what the
subject matter expert is saying that
swapping it sounds really like they're
swapping out they're swapping out the
previous Federal requirements which were
administratively added to the license
for these requirements which were in
place since 2016. whether or not they
impact the exact same entities it kind
of sounds like they do but again I need
to like look at this a little bit more
foreign
I think that um this you know was a
result of my comment and taking a look
at the um the fiscal impact like I said
the fiscal impact request didn't address
this thoroughly and um so it wasn't
discussed at all in the fiscal impact
statement that came out of the LBA the
agency couldn't get an amended fiscal
impact statement because that's you know
there's specific requirements in the
statute for that
so at the time when we discussed whether
or not it would be worthwhile getting
revised one
where folks landed was to come and have
the conversation in front of the
committee since they could not get an
amended request
it does seem to be a technical oversight
in their fiscal impact request that was
sent to the LBA
the committee has in the past
um you know approved such a thing
they've also not so it's up to the
committee
um you know how you want to
thank you
historically this has happened before
where there may have been a fee that was
in place federally for some time the and
everybody had been paying it but the
agency decided to
cite to the federal Rule and
but not mention it in the fiscal impact
statement and technically
uh representative McGuire is correct it
didn't exist in state law in state rules
beforehand
um I'm not sure I didn't review this I'm
not sure if the fee was actually in
place in the rules and they instead of
specifying that they are just now
referring to the CFR it I don't think
there's a problem if that's the case but
certainly if they are just for the first
time citing to defeat then technically
the rule has a change in it uh imposes a
fee that it did not impose before and uh
so that's been raised uh I think Kim is
right that in the past committees
usually gone along with it uh with a
notation to the agency but that's not
been that has not been up 100 scenario
there isn't there isn't a fee that's
what it was going there are no fee
requirements this is exactly just
adopting And discussing the additional
category one category two
content so there isn't a fiscal impact
because again per the agency and the
expert did not identify a fiscal impact
because there's no there's no fees
affiliated with this it's it's
encompassing and citing to a rule that's
already been existence of what has
already been in the requirement so
that's why when attorney Reeve brought
it to me I did ask her for her
recommendation to ensure that we
complied her statement regarding amended
fiscal impact is accurate
um and she said it probably actually
isn't even I forget how Kim phrased it
but it's not even like a thing probably
she was like oh it wouldn't even be
worth it to go back so we came here to
answer if there were questions but
um yeah I just wanted to clarify that
thank you though um
yes thank you whether there's a fee or
not does not definitively say whether
there's a fiscal impact if this requires
more secure or more expensive or more or
traceable or whatever containment
Vehicles that's a cost and it's a fiscal
impact
and I'm extremely concerned that HHS in
particular
merrily adopts Federal requirements
without getting the proper approval and
I'm not going to vote to support this
rule
yeah I mean I um
I wouldn't say you know we I wouldn't
say it that way I think you know
Department I'm new to this role I'm
doing how I've been taught and how I've
been trained and with communication with
the attorneys consistently and
constantly regarding rules again nuclear
Regulatory Commission and specifically
the radioactives has had other sort of
they have sort of other I don't know if
the words agreements or there are
certain things that you can't we can't
do because of the standards of NRC so we
fall back on not fall back on because we
have nothing else that we want to do but
there are things we literally cannot
change content-wise when it comes to
this because New Hampshire is an
agreement state with NRC so it's not a
falling back on the CFR it starts
certain things we're not even allowed to
change so they're already I forget what
it's called I've been looking at you
guys but yes
sorry
okay how these happen
is it seems to be a separate issue from
what costs are involved
it's not a matter of we yield to the
feds because they give us money it's how
much does this cost the citizens of New
Hampshire
so again we we don't we don't believe
there is a cost associated with this
um if you know I'll take whatever
recommendation attorney Reeve or
attorney morals say with respect to
writing that there might be an
indeterminable but again these licensees
are already under these requirements
this is just a citation to it but
they're already they already are
mandated these requirements we're not
talking about we're talking about the
costs incurred in obeying these rules
was there a fiscal impact statement in
approved in 2016 when we did approved
this derivative rule
I'm sure there was I'm sure there was
well that's that's something that needs
to be
now that you're applying it to in this
rule you'll say it's covered under the
cost for that rule
which was previously approved
Mike
thank you Mr chair if I can ask the
agency uh you've mentioned New Hampshire
being in agreement State uh is there any
codification in statute of New Hampshire
understand your question is how did the
New Hampshire become an agreement state
is it was there a statute that specified
that New Hampshire would be a member oh
I see it was uh back in 1966 whereby
then the governor and the New Hampshire
Administration
came to agreement with NRC that NRC
regulations would then be uh how should
I say transferred over to New Hampshire
to manage so would or without New
Hampshire NRC will still be controlling
the user react materials and also the
licensing and also the fees associated
with it it's simply transferred over the
the applications necessary to manage the
radioactive materials instead of under
NRC currently it's under New Hampshire
because of this 1966 agreement State com
uh agreement between NRC and New
Hampshire
thank you that that seems to be a
situation like with Environmental
Services where they have
um where the of the Agents of the
federal government and next essentially
for Clean Air Act Clean Water Act
Etc
and that is in RSA 125 F14 it's that
does state that um
that this is an agreement state
with Des for example they could just let
the EPA enforce the federal requirements
but the state
chose to have Des do that because they
thought it would be easier for the
citizens of the state to work with a
state agency and instead of trying to
work with the EPA
okay does somebody have a motion to
your staff recommendation
the committee could all could of course
postpone this if they wanted to have
further discussion regarding it
a bit of a motion and a second what do
is your emotions to postpones this may
require a waiver I'll ask him
the deadline is November December 19th
the Nova waiver would be necessary
okay
any further discussion
all those in favor of postponing bye
okay thank you can I ask a quick
question
the last item is an emergency rule
from Office of alcohol and drug abuse
prevention
um
as you're probably aware in certain
instances uh persons that have been
convicted of uh drunk driving have been
required by the courts to
undergo counseling they have to pay for
that at their own expense although there
is Provisions for Indigent persons
the state through HHS
and well through this office of alcohol
and drug the former office of alcohol
and drug abuse prevention
licenses providers who actually provide
the
there is various fees that are required
by Statute and in the rules
the department has recently sent out a
memo to the providers indicating that
the providers could not charge for
transaction fees in other words if a
client paid for his fees with a credit
card then
the agency was passing on the
transaction fees from the bank to the
client
the department said that that wasn't
currently authorized uh the providers
said well it's been current practice and
there was a cost uh that would be uh it
would strain their budgets uh so the
department agreed and put in the
emergency rule that authorized uh the
clients to be charged the transaction
fee there was also provision in there
that requires the providers to notify
the clients ahead of time of this fee
and let them know what it is before any
charge is made
there seems to be Authority regarding
this the the
rulemaking provision for Authority is
fairly broad so it seems to be within
their Authority
okay we don't take any action in this
is there any other business
uh yes staff would like to do a small
presentation
um
before the committee leaves
okay essentially we'd like to have some
cupcakes and thank the chair for his 12
years of service three years three terms
as Vice chair and three terms as chair
staff it was very appreciative of your
service and we want to thank you it was
only two two as a vice chair
okay
we have some cupcakes Okay interestingly
the only time that gel car wasn't able
to meet in December was the December
before Senator Reagan was um appointed
to gel Carr he started in January of
2013.
thank you for that I'm honored the
former director Scott Eaton is here
today
and it's been a pleasure to work with
the staff
and if everybody else the rules people
were here you could write this down and
send it to them I always encourage them
to
agree with the staff because that's how
we'll dispense with the continued
meeting
Mr chairman Scott came in because he he
okay